your mom wants you to have kids or is
she happy
uh my mother's a happy woman she said to
me oh
chip i don't have any kids believe me
they're gonna disappoint you
i'm like what do you mean ma she's like
forget it you have such high hopes and
they just turn out to be stupid failures
like ma what are you saying she's like
oh forget about it go have
supper my mother doesn't want me to have
children
your mother your mother had a friend uh
has raised you lamar he raised you right
lamar
no lamar is a friend from work release
lamar and reggie come over
they help my mother do like work in the
bedroom and fix the floorboards and
things like that
my father's an encyclopedia salesman and
has been on the road for many years
making the family fortune
he's a wonderful man my mother's a
marvelous woman
right so she's so he's been away and
they just they're always helping her
like that sounds like the project would
take a day or two why does it seem to be
going on for so long
i don't know that's a funny i asked my
mother at one time she said oh mind your
man is lyle
and she closed the door but i can always
they're always in their work and i just
hear
and i'm like ah that's my ma hard at
work with the work release program
fellas she's a marvelous lady and it's
nice especially you know with
kamala harris being vice president and
all the prominent you know feminists
that we have feminism that's going on
it's all it's nice that your mom's a big
proponent of that too she's all for
women's rights and
she's in there doing the manual labor
with the guys that's right my mother's a
marvelous hard worker
she can't do as much she's very
rubenesque and she has
gout and she has like that you know how
like sometimes somebody's a little bit
heavier than they should be
and uh they get skin tagged she's got
some skin tags
and gout so her workload has been a
little less lately the poor deer
well she spent so much time uh with
lamar what was the other general reggie
veggie today um i know because you know
for african americans this is a very
pivotal time in america in american
history
did reggie and lamar take a few days off
from helping your mom with the
floorboards
to protest did she go with them no
they're not big on protesting at all
they just try to keep a low profile in
the house
and i don't even know what nationality
reggie is he tells me he's from the
islands
and then he slaps me in the face and
goes in my mom's bedroom
what lamar used to do is him and his
friends would sit around and drink
miller light and he would make me do the
worm on the living
room rug while they watch the jeffersons
yeah i said well yeah i mean he was just
trying to teach you to dance a little
bit probably yes he was he told me to do
the worm
and i was actually very good at that
that's an old like from like beat street
and breaking
you know a lot of my references go back
before 1990 unfortunately
right right right right we really hope
you enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild